l'accident sur l' enquête sur l'accident
de lady diana le chauffeur de la voiture
conduisait en état d'ébriété alors que
l'on se font toujours beaucoup de
questions sur les circonstances exactes
de ce drame
dans ce journal nous entendrons un
témoignage capital celui d'un médecin
qui a apporté les tout premiers soins
aux victimes
les obsèques de la princesse de galles
auront lieu samedi matin à l'abbaye de
wesminster des obsèques quasi nationale
dans ce journal nous reviendrons
également sur le débat lancé sur
l'attitude des paparazzi avec le
témoignage de deux stars qui ont eu à
souffrir des moeurs d'une certaine
presse à scandale sandrine bonnaire et
william porte
bonsoir nous vous retrouvons dans un
instant madame monsieur madame monsieur
bonsoir les suites de l'enquêté sur les
circonstances de l'accident qui a coûté
la vie à la princesse diana son
compagnon et le chauffeur de la voiture
l'homme qui est sans doute le mieux
renseignés de france le ministre de
l'intérieur jean pierre chevènement l'a
lui même précisé
il convient d'être très prudent seul
élément véritablement nouveau
aujourd'hui dans un flot de rumeurs et
de témoignages contradictoires
le chauffeur de la voiture conduisait en
état d'ébriété avec un taux de 1 g 75
d'alcool ce qui représente un risque
d'accident est multiplié par 35 tout de
suite le point blank est valérie ermite
michel jeannot à tous
la mercedes 280 roulis très vite trop
vite eu 250 kilomètres/heure selon
certains témoins le conteur nuit se
serait bloqué aux alentours des 200
kilomètres heure mais les spécialistes
n'en tirait pour l'instant aucune
conclusion définitive il faudra attendre
la fin des expertises
l'élément nouveau lui est parvenue du
parquet de paris cet après midi
henri-paul le chauffeur qui travaillait
au ritz conduisait en état d'ébriété un
gramme 75 d'alcool dans le sang
au lieu des 0,5 toléré par la
législation française
le chauffeur aurait-il alors perdu tout
seul le contrôle de sa voiture
ou encore comme l'expliquent un témoin
l'avocat de la famille al-fayed
aurait-il été gêné par un motard qui
zigzaguait devant lui il a pensé qu'il
s'agissait
un cortège officiel et puis à pénétrant
dans le tunnel de l'alma
il a ensuite vu une moto qui se trouvait
devant le véhicule mercedes qui semblait
et tentait d'empêcher sa progression
seul trait vori jones garde du corps de
lady diana unique survivant de
l'accident pourrait confirmer ou non
cette hypothèse
une hypothèse que les enquêteurs
jugerait cependant peu probable
l'implication directe dans l'accident
des paparazzi pourrait même être écarté
leurs motos se serait trouvé au moins à
100 mais derrière la voiture
reste alors la polémique sur l'attitude
des photographes
après l'accident des photographes une
main anonyme a déjà désigné comme
coupable
c'était moins un américain arrivé avant
les secours ont effectivement vu des
photographes autour de la voiture mais
il ne parle pas de gêne particulière
oui on a vu des photographes et qu'est
ce qu'il faisait mais il traînait autour
de la watch valley où je peux pas dire
que j'en ai vu un prendre des photos
mais il était dans le coin
d'autres en revanche affirmé avoir vu
mitraillé la voiture les paparazzis
aurait-il continuer à prendre des photos
sans avoir essayé de porter secours
c'est sur cette notion de non assistance
à personne en danger qu'il pourrait être
poursuivi
avec précisément un témoignage capital
sur ce drame celui d'un médecin arrivé
très peu de temps après l'embardée de la
mercedes e frederik mayet bonsoir alors
je tiens tout de suite a rappelé bien
sûr que vous êtes tenus au secret
professionnel au secret médical et qu'il
est bien évidemment pas question de
parler une seconde dans l'état des
victimes simplement est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter ce qui s'est passé
l'autre soir vous arriviez sur l'autre
voie dans ce tunnel de l'alma l'autre
voie je riais une soirée privée et quand
je me suis embarqué dans le tunnel j'ai
vu qu'elle est la fumée j'ai vu qu'il y
avait une voiture accidentée
effectivement dans le sens inverse et un
ralentissement qui m'ont obligé à
m'arrêter pratiquement au niveau de la
voiture et à traire les plier j'ai vu
qu'ils avaient un accident grave
je suis allé voir ce qui se passait et
faire un premier bilan comme j'ai
l'habitude de faire du samu j'ai vu il y
avait deux mondes deux blessés graves et
donc j'ai
tout de suite couru dans ma voiture pour
prévenir les secours jacques les
pompiers donné un premier bilan médical
prendre un petit peu de matériel et
porter secours aux victimes
alors question parce qu'il ya polémique
y avait déjà des badauds déjà des
photographes
est ce que ces badauds ou ses
photographes vous ont gêné d'une
quelconque manière
il m'a pas gêné du tout ils ont agi
exactement comme tout badauds agit en t1
quand ils voient un accident grave ils
ont ils étaient autour de la voiture
aussitôt que je suis arrivé je me suis
présentée comme médecin ils se sont
écartés et ils m'ont laissé porter
secours aux victimes
il y avait environ une douzaine une
quinzaine de photographes épisode du
genre effectivement il prenait des
photos derrière moi ils m'ont aidé dans
le sens où ils m'ont
ils m'ont dit que les personnes par les
anglais qui n'ont pas révélé l'identité
j'ai pas reconnu les personnes mais ils
m'auraient ils m'ont dit qu'ils
parlaient anglais ce qui aurait pu
m'aider si les personnes avaient pu vous
répondre
donc on dit qu'il pourrait y avoir
non-assistance à personne en danger de
la part de certains photographes
actuellement entendues au quai des
orfèvres qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous vous dites que ils vous ont baissé
trà vinh ans et que de toute façon rien
n'est pire que quelqu'un qui n'est pas
du miti s'occupe de blessés absolument
d'accord le principe c'est de ne pas
nuire et a priori on ne peut pas toucher
un blessé grave
moi j'ai l'habitude ça fait dix ans que
je fais du samu et donc je savais à peu
près quoi faire et donc c'est ce que
j'ai fait il n'avait pas à intervenir et
valait mieux qu'ils n'interviennent pas
toutes à la question vous avez été
interrogé par les policiers
servez merci fait avec ma nièce pour ce
témoignage angles a dit tout à l'heure
on a su avec les résultats de l'autopsié
que le conducteur de cette voiture avait
un taux d'alcoolémie de 1 g 75 tours
propose de revoir tout de suite
maintenant compagnie de janvier d'effets
les acquis ce que prévoit la législation
en vigueur
des tests l'ont montré l'alcoolémie
varie certes avec le poids la corpulence
la nature des repas et le sexe mais au
premier ver déjà les réflexes sont
altérées campo monde comme on peut le
voir ici et après deux vers l'ailé flex
sont même franchement émoussé une
alcoolémie de 1 g 75 correspond à une
consommation d'alcool importante au
moins 8000 bière bien quatre double
whisky une alcoolémie incompatibles avec
la conduite d'un véhicule
la limite légale en france et de 0 g 50
limite que certains spécialistes
trouvent encore trop permissive
le père de dodi al fayed a d'ores et
déjà annoncé son intention de se porter
sa partie civile dès qu'une information
judiciaire sera ouverte ce qui devrait
être fait très prochainement par le
parquet de paris
en attendant les policiers continuent
d'interroger les photographes interpellé
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche je
vous propose de retrouver tout de suite
en direct du quai des orfèvres
christophe thomas christophe la garde à
vue va se prolonger jusqu'à minuit et
ensuite que va-t-il se passer tout h et
bruno les sept hommes sont toujours
entendus par les policiers l'heure
légale de garde à vue va être mené
jusqu'à 100 terme c'est à dire jusqu'à
00h30 précisément ce soir pourtant
certains photographes ne seront pas
présentés au parquet avant demain matin
le parking qui pourrait alors ouvrir une
information judiciaire selon nos
informations trois ou quatre paparazzi
pourrait être mise en examen pour
non-assistance à personne en danger
ce sont eux ce serait eux qui auraient
continué à prendre des clichés après le
drame les policiers ont saisi leur
téléphone portable pour voir quelle a
été leur attitude leur premier geste
après l'accident ils ont saisi les
pellicules ils ont développé
ils ont également effectué des
perquisitions à l'intérieur des agences
de ses photographes par contre il semble
que la qualification d'homicide
involontaire ne serait pas retenue par
le procureur de la république de paris
cela dit les hommes de la pj poursuivent
leurs investigations et la recherche
semble-t-il d'autres photographes mais
tout à fait il semble qu'il y ait un ou
deux photographes qui réussit à prendre
des clichés de l'accident et qui réussit
à échapper au contrôle des policiers
après ces photographes qui ont proposé
un journal anglais pour des millions de
francs un journal américain pour 6
millions de francs les clichés du drame
les directeurs de ces publications ont
pour l'instant refusé ces photos mais
les policiers sont évidemment à la
recherche de ces photos grâce pour les
entendre au moins en qualité de témoin
merci christophe torrent pour ces
précisions j'ajoute que le quotidien
populaire allemand bild a publié dans
son édition déjà deux photos de cet
accident
des photos plutôt floue et semble-t-il
prise de loin
à paris plusieurs centaines de personnes
se sont présentées dès ce matin
l'ambassade de grande bretagne pour y
déposer des bouquets de fleurs en
hommage à la mémoire de la princesse de
galles et signer un registre de
condoléances
où l'on pouvait relever ce genre de
propos tu es parti trop vite mais tu as
su parler à des milliers de coeurs et
ses milliers de coeurs doré
l'émotion est réel un peu partout dans
le monde mais c'est bien évidemment en
grande bretagne qu'elle est la plus
manifeste
la presse britannique a d'ores et déjà
dresser un véritable mausolée à lady
diana
entré au panthéon des célébrités
inoubliable reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux jacques cardoze jacques garnich
l'amitié de tout un peuple
peu à peu au gré du temps la dimension
des sentiments de la nation à l'égard de
la princesse de galles se fait jour
fleurs et poèmes viennent colorer les
abords de la chapelle st james où repose
la défunt quelques mots chuchotés une
photo un souvenir chacun y va de son
témoignage
je ne sais pas comment elle a trouvé le
temps de faire tout ce qu'elle faisait
je l'aimé moi depuis le début elle
aidait les gens ordinaires
et ils étaient plusieurs milliers
d'anonymes venus se recueillir et
célébrer la mémoire de la princesse
avant que celle-ci ne reçoivent les
honneurs officiels samedi prochain en
fin de matinée dès ce matin un cahier de
doléances a été ouvert au public dans la
chapelle où repose la dépouille mortelle
j'espère qu'elle aura vraiment les plus
belles funérailles parce que les gens
ici sont très choqués je suis persuadé
qu'il lui faut des funérailles
nationales
je me souviens les gens ont été
tellement heureux de l'avoir dans les
rues lorsqu'elle s'est mariée avec le
prince charles
c'est vraiment le dernier hommage
qu'elle mérite à buckingham la famille
royale observe un deuil national moins
formelle que le deuil général ou le
deuil de cours les obsèques seront
nationale est quasi royale en présence
de chefs d'état étrangers magasins
fermés rencontres sportives reporter ou
minute de silence
comme ce matin la city la place
boursière de londres des décisions en
réponse au chagrin de tout un peuple
la duchesse d'york sarah ferguson était
en vacances en italie avec ses deux fils
lorsqu'elle a appris la disparition de
lady die fair j comme on l'appelle le
familièrement a déclaré avoir perdu une
soeur et sa meilleure amie sarah
ferguson a divorcé l'année dernière avec
le fils cadet de la reine d'angleterre
le prince andrew
nous retrouvons direct notre
correspondant permanent à londres
etienne leenhardt etienne tout d'abord y
at-il en angleterre une réaction à
l'information du jour à savoir le taux
d'alcoolémie élevé du conducteur de la
voiture dans laquelle les dix derrière
trouver
oui bonsoir vous imaginez bien que dès
que cette information est tombée sur les
agences de presse elle a immédiatement
été relayée par toutes les chaînes de
télévision et notamment la chaîne
d'information continue skynews qui a
incrusté cette information pendant deux
ou trois heures de façon ininterrompue
il est encore trop tôt pour savoir s'il
y aura véritablement une polémique il
faudra sans doute attendre la sortie des
journaux populaires qui ont relativement
souvent un sentiment anti français assez
développée pour savoir si la polémique
va rebondir ou si le deuil et l'émotion
nationale qui déferle ici le mot n'est
pas trop fort prendront le pas sur cette
polémique
les obsèques de la princesse seront lus
on l'a dit samedi à 11h des obsèques de
dimension nationale sans être
spécifiquement royal pour reprendre la
formule d'un porte parole du palais de
buckingham il s'agira d'une cérémonie
unique pour une personnalité unique wii
sera unique à plusieurs titres d'abord
par son ampleur car sommes tous les
observateurs ici sont persuadés que des
centaines de milliers de britanniques
vont venir se recueillir notamment sur
le passage du cortège qui amènera la
dépouille de la princesse de galles vers
l'abbaye de westminster
des centaines de milliers de
britanniques se sont attendus bien
évidemment compte tenu de l'émotion qui
secoue le pays
et puis elles sont uniques parce que
vous savez qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
discussions sur les problèmes
protocolaires puisque la princesse de
galles ne fait plus partie de la famille
royale et que l'on attendait avec
beaucoup d'impatience la décision de la
reine elizabeth qui vous savez a donc
choisi
partiquement des obsèques à dimension
nationale même si on ne peut pas parler
d'obsèques royal en acceptant que la
cérémonie funèbre et lieu dans l'abbaye
de westminster merci etienne pour ces
précisions ces obsèques solennelles en
tout cas se dérouleront donc à l'abbaye
de westminster un lieu hautement
symbolique pour la monarchie britannique
comme le rappelle etienne et nantes
comme tous les drapeaux du pays celui
qui flotte sur l'abbaye de westminster
est en berne depuis hier matin
c'est donc ici que seront célébrées
samedi les obsèques de la princesse de
galles pour tous les croyants du royaume
qui cet après midi encore arpenter les
églises pour rendre hommage à leurs
princesses seul westminster pouvait être
digne de l'adieu d'un pays accablé à sa
princesse défunte l'abbaye de wesminster
c'est un peu comme notre dame chaud
l'abbaye est un endroit très
réconfortant et donc très approprié et
puis surtout l'abbaye de wesminster
abrite sous celle des années et des
siècles d'histoire
c'est ici que tous les souverains
d'angleterre ont été couronnés des
mariages royaux y ont été consacrés
celui de la reine elizabeth
celui de son fils en brousse
honneur et malheurs d'un royaume c'est à
westminster aussi curieux les obsèques
de seurre winston churchill une abbaye
donc réservé aux illustres du royaume
dont diana fait partie même si elle
vivait en marge de la famille royale
cérémonie sera unique parce que ce sont
à la fois des obsèques ordinaire diana
n'est plus officiellement membre de la
famille mais en même temps à travers la
présence de la reine
ce seront des funérailles royal
westminster pour diana la décision de la
reine elizabeth sonne incontestablement
comme une réponse à l'émotion qui depuis
deux jours a saisi le pays
cette cérémonie sera bien évidemment
retransmit en direct samedi matin sur
france 2 avec auparavant une édition
spéciale de la rédaction
la princesse reposera dans le mausolée
familial construit en 15 sans cesse dans
une chapelle de l'église de grippe
bénigne tonnes tout proche de la demeure
ancestrale des spencer à assen dans le
centre de l'angleterre
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
bernard lebrun fidh et l'anddh un
village typiquement anglais aussi petit
qu'un inconnu jusqu alors avec 200
habitants plutôt riche et retraités et
qui redoute par dessus tout les hordes
de visiteurs dès ce matin les officiers
de police et de sécurité de sa majesté
ont inspecté l'église de sainte-marie de
la vierge car à l'intérieur se trouve la
chapelle familiale des comptes spencer
huit siècles d'histoire vingt
générations présentes
c'est ici près de son père décédé il ya
cinq ans que sera inhumé la princesse de
galles
la fièvre monte à gwatt be around town
où l'on ne veut surtout pas devenir un
même fils avec sa tombe d'elvis au
contraire les paroissiens entendent bien
faire respecter la stricte volonté
d'intimité vous vis par la famille
spencer 800 mètres plus bas dans la
vallée
derrière les murs se cache alfort paul
le château des spencer élevé au xvième
siècle la maison de la jeune diana une
demeure qu'elle jugeait de tristes et
qu'elle n'est m'a pas beaucoup mais
c'est là que la princesse a grandi alors
là aussi devant les grilles on se
recueille
et l'on vient déposer des fleurs des
mères et des enfants surtout silencieux
volontairement distants des journalistes
quelques lignes accompagnent leurs books
à la reine des coeurs dans nos coeurs
pour toujours des fleurs pour vous des
larmes pour nous la princesse de galles
était surtout connu au travers le monde
sous son prénom
diana mariée au prince charles il était
devenu windsor divorcée elle était
redevenu lady spencer son nom de baptême
et c est dans ce fief historique de sa
famille qu'elle reposera désormais à
partir de samedi la princesse diana
dynamique moderne politique m'engager
grande communicatrice avait passablement
bousculer une monarchie figé et hautaine
la princesse de galles à insuffler des
changements probablement irréversible
notamment dans l'esprit de ses deux
enfants
le très sérieux finishers times
l'affirmé lui-même aujourd'hui dans un
éditorial
la monarchie ne pourra plus jamais être
la même commentaire geneviève moll
finalement c'est cette image là que la
princesse de galles a tenté de faire
exploser celle d'une monarchie qu'au
passé dans laquelle au début elle a
essayé de s'inscrire
adoptant même les couvre chef des dames
de la famille pendant un temps elle a
même été la mer qu'on attendait mais les
déboires de sa vie intime l'ont rendue à
sa vraie personnalité celle d'une jeune
femme libre coca malheurs du monde ne
laissait la différence
à ce moment là d'aucuns ont dit qu'elles
détruisent est la monarchie moi je crois
que c'est tout la verse
je crois au contraire qu'elle a
formidablement moderniser l'institution
d'abord elle a régné depuis son divorce
est une femme qui a régné elle a
parcouru l'humour d'elles s'est exprimée
elle a régné en apportant une voie à une
monarchie muette
la première fois membre de la famille
royale a peu parlé avec des gens les
pauvres ils se feront les toucher et
consoler et ça c'est nouveau
si lady diana avait poursuivi son
parcours il est probable que l'image de
la monarchie en aurait été changée
sa disparition va t'elle tout arrêter et
charles peut-il encore épousé camilla
parker bowles
je pense qu'il pourra pas épouser camus
est parce que ya cette mort tragique on
trouve qu'à la fresque entre eux et puis
la reine elizabeth n'annonce pas son
désir d'appliquer pour le moment le trô
ne pourrait donc bien échapper un charme
vieillissant et revenir à son fils aîné
william qui devrait mettre en oeuvre
veritas spirituel de lady diana
je crois qu'elle a préparé son fils ça
devenir un roi citoyen si on peut dire
un peu comme dans les monarchies
nordiques ou pour finir le roi n'a pas
de sujet mais des concitoyens
c'est à dire qu'ils participent à la vie
du pays il parle quand il a envie de
parler quand il a quelque chose à dire
c'est pas un symbole mu s est pas un aux
consommateurs c'est un acteur de la vie
publique
un guide pour sa version tout repose
donc maintenant sur les épaules de ce
prince de 15 ans élevé comme un futur
roi par son père et comme un citoyen par
sa mère nous allons maintenant revenir
sur le grand débat a lancé sur les
méthodes d'une certaine presse avec
elle de ce que prévoit la loi sur la
protection de la vie privée rappelle
également du poids économique de ce que
l'on appelle la presse à scandale et le
témoignage dans quelques instants de
deux acteurs qui ont eu pas mal à
souffrir de ce genre de presse dans leur
vie privée
sandrine bonnaire et william offre pour
reprendre un titre de la presse
italienne
diana est morte comme elle a vécu sous
les flashs des projecteurs et des
photographes quelles que soient les
conclusions de l'enquêté sur l'accident
les paparazzis sont déjà montrées du
doigt dans l'opinion reportage daniel
wolfromm rim et poissonniers l' agence
gamma est une des trois premières
agences de photo au monde de leurs
reporters a été interpellé après
l'accident de la princesse diana un coup
dur qui ne remet toutefois pas en cause
le fait que le tiers du chiffre
d'affaires de l'entreprise repose sur
les images de star il est de fait que
les grands magazines de la planète que
le time magazine que paris match pour
satisfaire leurs lecteurs sont amenés à
leur présenter plus de sujets dits
people sûr
les grands de ce monde sur les
politiques sur les acteurs les stars
c'est une évolution qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui le people est devenue une
partie intégrante du news qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
sur le fond quand vous êtes abreuver
toute la semaine d'image dramatique de
télévision peut-être que la tendance
naturelle du lecteur
c'est de se reposer sur un sujet
magazine d'actualité dit heureuse c'est
cette logique du marché que conteste le
photographe francis a pesté guy lui même
un ancien paparazzi devenu aujourd'hui
un repenti moi j'aime bien la vérité
même si elle fait mal il faut en passer
par la vérité on peut pas continuer
comme ça la vérité c'est quoi c'est que
c'est un commerce à grande échelle
c'est le commerce de la subtilité avec
d'état d'intervenants jean michel aulas
n'a pas ces états d'âme il dirige une
agence de cinq reporters pour lui la
liaison d'une princesse cite une
information comme une autre c'est à dire
que le marché fait que quand on met une
photo de 2
de massacres en algérie à la ligne de
paris match
ça va vendre moins que si on met un
baiser de lady di avec dodi al fayed
je dirais que là on va pas refaire le
monde même si cette logique du marché
semble implacable
le débat aujourd'hui a le mérite d'être
lancé sur le banc des accusés les
paparazzi et surtout les éditeurs d'une
certaine presse à scandales font donc
remarquer que le public est demandeur de
photos à sensation et force est de
constater que ce type de presse ne fait
qu augmenter ses ventes au fil des mois
enquête marielle ngono patricia charnolé
la presse people en france c'est celle
qui parle des gens célèbres sept titres
ils sont en partie ou totalement
consacré paris match vsd gala voici
france dimanche
ici paris point de vue leur diffusion
hebdomadaire est de trois millions trois
cent mille exemplaires
plus de 20 millions de lecteurs les
lisent chaque semaine leurs chiffres
d'affaires annuels représentent deux
milliards deux cent mille francs un
poids économique énorme une progression
constante des ventes
le tournant c'est fait il ya dix ans
avec la publication en france deux
journaux comme voici issus du puissant
groupe d'origine allemande prisma presse
les équipes d'axa lugansky public
allemand gala ont apporté les méthodes
utilisées outre-rhin des photos beaucoup
de photos des équipes réduites ce qui
limite les coûts des stars et encore des
stars et le public y trouve son compte
dans leur vie et objective quelquefois
il paraît même par hélicoptère ça ça me
laisse un petit peu sceptique mais
malgré tout je sais tu es en fait qui
est très amusant c'est que cette le
journal mais j'ai au moins cinq ou six
personnes derrière moi qui refuse c'est
qui le lie fera derrière quand il salue
aussi comme moi le syndicat français de
la presse magazine qui représente la
quasi totalité des titres réagi avec une
certaine sérénité aux attaques lancées
depuis hier contre la profession selon
ces professionnels
la presse people française est l'une des
meilleures du monde il y a dans le
procès qui lui est fait beaucoup
d'hypocrisie on vilipende aisément cette
forme de presse pour vol des photos et
atteinte à la vie privée
on se rend compte à l'examen des
dossiers que les photos sont fréquemment
reportage fréquemment paru avec
l'autorisation des personnes pour les
financiers de la presse le développement
actuel des magazines consacrés aux stars
n'est pas près de s'arrêter
d'autant que le phénomène a fait tâche
d'huile c'est une presse qui se
développe parce que le pipole envahi je
dirais l'ensemble des médias y compris
les autres catégories de presse -
spécifiques et cette question qui agite
en effet la profession
kelly le média aujourd'hui presse écrite
radio télévision qui renonceraient à
parler de la vie privée des stars
chacun à sa façon il consacre quelques
minutes où des dizaines de pages chacun
aujourd'hui doit réfléchir au respect de
la vie privée et à la liberté d'informer
invité des 4 vérités ce matin sur france
2 catherine trautmann a estimé
nécessaire un code de bonne conduite
pour la presse porte parole du
gouvernement a rappelé que la loi
française était la plus protectrice en
la matière l'article 9 du code civil
dispose que chacun a droit au respect de
sa vie privée reste à appliquer dans la
vie quotidienne ce concept sacro-saint
domi verdeilhan dans cette salle du
palais de justice de paris résonne
souvent les noms de caroline de monaco
sophie marceau juliette binoche hallyday
ce jour là les stars ne sont pas
présentes mais leurs avocats viennent
poursuivre des journaux parce qu'une
photo le plus
à porter atteinte à leur vie privée le
code pénal prévoit une peine allant
jusqu'à un an de prison et 300 millions
d'amoureux les personnalités choisissent
plutôt la voie civile parce que la
réparation financière y est plus fort
cinquante mille francs
cent mille francs récemment isabelle
adjani a obtenu trois cent mille francs
de dommages et intérêts ce n'est pas la
photo qui est interdite c'est sa
publication
juridiquement c'est donc le journal qui
est poursuivi et non le photographe
chacun a droit au respect de sa vie
privée stipule la loi
interdiction donc de révéler les amours
les divorces les maternités l'état de
santé la croyance et le domicile et pour
certains avocats
cet arsenal juridique ne dissuade pas
assez les patrons de presse
si vous prenez un journal comme voici il
est condamné 4,5 foire chaque mercredi
devant la première chambre du tribunal
de paris bien les indemnités rentrer
dans ses frais généraux
je crois qu'il faut en venir en france à
ce qu'on pourrait appeler à l'instar des
états unis des dommages intérêts
punitifs
les sommes sont versées à des fondations
où elle serait versée au trésor mais en
tout cas elle tiendrait compte du
harcèlement du comportement de celui qui
prend le cliché et pas seulement du
préjudice matériel qu'a subie ou qui n'a
pas subi
celui qui a été sa victime la france est
l'un des pays où la vie privée la plus
protégée
demain les enfants de la princesse
pourraient à leur tour se tourner vers
les tribunaux français si jamais une
photo publiée venait ternir l'image de
leur mère invité de notre journal de
sandrine bonnaire et william hurt
bonsoir vous avez vécu ensemble à nous
et vous avez eu beaucoup à souffrir sur
un plan personnel et privé de certaines
pratiques de cette presse à scandale
avec réaffirmation rumeur ou photos
volées qu'est ce qui vous est arrivé par
exemple précisément on a
je voudrais avant tout dire que je
trouve que sans des gens qui violent et
qui vole les lecteurs parce que leurs
informations sont fausses
donc le tout dernier article qui était
paru dans voici et est totalement faux
il a peut-être plus grand chose à dire
sur mon jeu c'est pas donc je trouve que
c'est un manque de respect vis-à-vis des
artistes et en plus du lecteur quoi donc
en fait ce qui nous ont fait passer des
photos volées des photos de notre enfant
je crois que ça c'est le plus terrible
et puis oui de une famille notre
intimité alors vous avez une réaction
assez symbolique on va en voir des
images dans un instant vous êtes allés
déposer du fumier devant l'hebdomadaire
fois ci nous allons revoir à ses images
des images tirées d'un reportage dans
les spéciales un reportage que vous
pourrez revoir jeudi prochain alors
cette action était éminemment symbolique
on l'a dit tout à l'heure la seule chose
c'est de frapper ses journées au
portefeuille mais les amendes sont assez
faibles et puis de toute façon le mal
est fait la diffamation elle court
toujours
oui elle court toujours il faudrait il
faudrait qu il qu'il y ait une loi qui
est parce que le problème c'est que on a
donc le droit de notre image de notre
vie notre intimité et puis en même temps
il ya eu il ya la liberté de la presse
donc ça
je trouve qu'il faudrait trouver une
chose entre les deux parce que ça ça
fait terriblement souffrir surtout quand
quand c'est flou c'est en plus on
devient complètement parano ça va sur
des gens à peu près solide mais sur
d'autres il ya mieux que vous avez vous
êtes américains y la presse américaine
aussi est assez rude quand il faut et
vous avez vous même à souffrir de
certaines moeurs notamment un procès
privé entièrement télévisée j'ai eu
cette expérience
aux etats unis c'est ce même plus
difficile se défendre
qu'ici en france je pense en france
c'est mieux mais ça vient ici le
problème est que s'il ya une photographe
qui a la droit de prendre des photos de
loin avec 1 600 mm caméra de choses
privées
quelle joie lui les fonds qu'elle quelle
loi mais permet de violer la privas
c'est d'un autre femme est spécialement
comme dans le cas de diana quand on en a
vu une image pathétique qu'elle est
sortie de je me souviens de sa
psychologue elle était évident dans aide
dans une émotion très fort elle n'a pas
être regardé par les étrangers et elle
sait se défendre mais n'a pas pu se
défendre et cette image reste avec moi
avec les autres images de cette femme
qui était très très bonne très très très
généreuse que quand on est une grande
star c puis file de ce point de vue là
de vivre aux états unis ou en france
pour selon-vous selon votre expérience
c'est plus difficile mais je pense après
après avoir vu
notamment de toi commencement de voix si
d autres choses ici que vient s est fait
je pense pas que parce qu'on dit les
lecteurs on est beaucoup sur les
lecteurs mais je vais l'annoncer achète
chaque semaine on a dit tout à l'heure
les titres people com oui mais je pense
que si on leur propose autre chose
il irait peut-être autre chose je pense
qu'on prend vraiment le lecteur pour un
cochon quoi et c'est bien dommage merci
beaucoup d'être venu témoigner sur ce
plateau un débat qui est loin d'être
clos malheureusement dans l'actualité
également des chiffres plutôt
inquiétants concernant le marché
automobile français
les ventes de voitures particulières ont
en effet chuté de 29% au mois d'août par
rapport au même mois de l'an dernier et
les perspectives s'annoncent moroses
pour les tout prochains mois
reportage au sébastien guibert et
frédéric rostaing dérapages saisonniers
ou chute incontrôlée
en tout cas les mauvais chiffres du mois
d'août révèle à marché automobile très
fragilisés pour ce concessionnaire
parisien comme pour la plupart de ses
collègues en france les ventes de
véhicules neufs ont baissé en un an de
près de 30 % signe un paradoxal d'un
véritable malaise l'accroissement des
ventes d'occasion on peut penser qu'une
partie de la clientèle pour les
d'acheter des voitures neuves s'est
reportée sur de la voiture d'occasion et
ce qui est d'autant plus intéressant
c'est que ces deux l'occasion récente
des voitures d'un an ou deux qui
économiquement sont peut-être plus
accessible actuellement pour la
clientèle depuis trois ans le marché
sous perfusion la prime balladur suivi
de la prime juppé ont gonflé
artificiellement les carnets de
commandes des constructeurs
aujourd'hui l'effet dopant des
subventions a disparu principales
victimes peugeot et citroën renault
limitent la casse grâce au succès de ses
petits modèles
le mois d'août est normalement un mois
creux je ne considère pas que le niveau
d'immatriculation du mois d'août
conduisent à réviser les prévisions de
marché qu'on peut faire sur l'année pour
la france
très probablement le mois de septembre
ne sera pas meilleur octobre à ses
moyens tous les espoirs reposent donc
sur les deux derniers mois de l'année
d'après les prévisions l'année 97
enregistrera une baisse de 20% des
ventes par rapport à l'an passé
pour les constructeurs français des
exportations se portent plutôt bien
merci
mais il faudra encore beaucoup
d'imagination et de détermination pour
rétablir la santé du malade
les clubs à 100 sièges dans la qualité
également la rentrée de la maternelle à
la troisième ils seront plus de 10
millions a poussé jeudi la porte d'un
établissement scolaire
le gouvernement a réaffirmé la priorité
donnée à la réouverture ou au maintien
des classes en zone rurale cela concerne
800 classe exemple avec ce reportage
d'olivier caroff et de domique merlin
dans une petite commune du calvados dans
le préau une fresque annonce la couleur
ici plus il ya d'enfants mieux on se
porte
la directrice de l'école primaire a fait
ses calculs onze élèves de plus inscrits
cette année cela veut dire une classe et
un enseignant supplémentaire
nous allons installer le
l instituteur ouest est stricte tout est
prêt pour la rentrée de jeudi
l'an dernier cette salle ne servait pas
à grand-chose faute d'élèves en zone
rurale l'ouverture d'une classe peut
considérablement améliorer les résultats
scolaires fait changer tout à fait
l'année scolaire oui puisque les enfants
seront moins nombreux par classe donc
beaucoup moins de fatigue pour eux
beaucoup les enseignants beaucoup plus
de temps pour s'occuper d'eux et quand
on passe de 30 élèves dans une classe à
21,22 on voit la différence mais la
sphère ne concerne pas que les enfants
une ouverture de classe dans un village
c'est aussi pour les adultes un signe de
prospérité
c'est un beau cadeau oui pour une
commune c'est évident parce que
l'ouverture de deux classes montre la
vitalité du hms d'une commune rurale à
ces modèles sans population puisque nous
avons 1620 habitants c'est à dire ces
taxes est un village en réalité un
village qui il y a dix ans avait vu une
classe fermée depuis on a investi pour
enrayer l'exode rural des lotissements à
loyer modéré un centre sportif flambant
neufs des efforts aujourd'hui payant
l'école maternelle de vassy aura elle
aussi une classe en plus ce jeudi qui
dit rentrée dit fin des vacances et
réciproquement avec au moins une bonne
nouvelle dans ce journal la hausse de la
fréquentation touristique de notre beau
pays grâce notamment à la clientèle
étrangère au total la progression de la
fréquentation touristique se situe selon
les régions
dans une fourchette de 5 à 15% en
moyenne les français sont partis deux
semaines en vacances au total 8 millions
de touristes ont passé l'été dans le
languedoc roussillon dont la moitié
venait de l'étranger
reportage à la grande mode karine
comazzi françoise maso premiers jours de
septembre est déjà un parfum de rentrée
sur la grande motte il y a quelques
jours encore la plage était bondée comme
tout le littoral languedocien qui a tiré
cet été pas moins de 6 millions de
touristes
des chiffres qui font de la région la
troisième destination touristique
française en hiver petit jour en moyenne
et en consomment relativement peu mais
on a quand même
une journée ou deux découvertes et je
crois que dans ce domaine là il ya une
augmentation de la recherche de la
découverte de du proche arrière-pays de
la méditerranée le crew 97 confirment
les tendances de l'an passé le touriste
français préfèrent partir une ou deux
semaines mais plusieurs fois dans
l'année et porte une attention toute
particulière à la qualité de son
hébergement
il vient moins longtemps mais quand il
est là il veut être bien logés sont le
logement l'hébergement est très
important actuellement et les locataires
privilégie l'équipement le confort le
luxe entre guillemets de l'appartement
côté nourriture les vacances et se
serrent la ceinture une pierre de
rigueur qui force le restaurateur à
s'adapter
aujourd'hui c'était le menu du près la
rose ses vacances seulement quand c'est
bien oui parce que ça permet
d'équilibrer un peu le budget de corps
sur la façon dont on a les premiers
touchés comme ça les économies sur le
budget c'est pour nous et encore plus
sur le déjeuner c'est vrai qu'il réduise
davantage leurs dépenses sur sur ce
point la saison est bonne comment faites
vous et bien une grâce à des soirées on
se connaissait davantage de se remettre
en question on essaie de créer des
événements
des efforts payants puisque la grande
motte estime avoir attiré cette année 20
% de touristes de plus que l'an passé
d'année journal le fip le fait vers
00h15 demain dans les 4 vérités à 7h50
j'ai relevé recevra lech walesa bonne
fête aux gîtes dans un instant le
rappelle météo sophie davant très très
bonne soirée merci ça donne
m